oft genug in die lage ein
das ist ein kleines problem das ist ein
klitzekleines problem
das geht so nicht willkommen zu einer
neuen folge handicap games wie spiel
heute ein handicap was ich letztens in
den kommentaren gelesen
danke dass sie wieder kommentare
geschrieben habt und zwar lautet das
spiel doch mal alleine eine runde teams
games so als kleines handicap rucksack
und wir haben jetzt leider die channels
und ich bekommen dass er sehr schön
geworden gewesen ihr seht jetzt hier
rechts geworden wie ihr seht ihr rechts
teams erlaubt beim bildschirm
ich spiele in einer team ist die runde
spiele natürlich allein ich habe keinen
versteckten partner irgendwo vergraben
der sich dann später ausbildet und sagte
ich bin's organist schwer traugott geil
ja das ist ein klarer fall von kairo
dann holte erst mal den hier alles klar
der grim reaper der weg dann ist da
hinten noch einer das gesicht lama
gesicht lachte sich tut mir leid mein
liebes lachte sich das blatt
das heißt ganz schön schwierig das zu
sagen es tut mir wirklich wirklich leid
okay okay ist gerade wie mega leicht mit
diesen schritten dieser geilen rüstung
leute weg zu recken tyrannosaurus rex
werde ich auch genannt dass man neue
xbox magazins recht einfach wenn er mit
stil sagen wollt dass jemand zerstört
habt dann schreibt einfach tyrannosaurus
rex ryan
dann denkt sie hier die aida aprilia
weiß bescheid
er ist teil des durchaus 2 gegen
hoffmanns lampen oft mal da oben gehen
dieses gebäude war wirklich
wahrscheinlich auf dem ziel handeln
jump'n'run oder ist es ein team
der sound erklärt er das mit seinem
partner hier ein bisschen regen
sein teampartner erscheint aber auch
schon gut auf die mütze bekommen zu
haben da kommt mir gar nicht der haut
sogar ab so habe was mit dir sagst du
bist alles klar
alles super entspannen das aber schon
fünf leute hertie messgewand ist hätte
ich nicht gedacht alter tillich das
läuft gut man und jodi hatten gutes
equipment
wir sind jetzt auch ja fast von einem
stützpunkt fehlt noch das gefällt mir
doch sehr gut
leute ihr könnt natürlich gerne wieder
eure challengers in die kommentare
schreiben
was er auf dem herzen liegt und ich weiß
du bei mir das kommt gerade die alles
von selbst also ich hoffe dass mir jetzt
keine abstarb in dieser geilen runde
irgendwie so einfach dieses ganze kinder
von selbst wir sind ein kleiner
automatismus für richtig cool muss gar
nicht groß nachdenken liegt
wahrscheinlich daran dass ihr letzter
zeit häufiger an die atp geschockt habe
den lieben doch sehr guter tipp falls
ihr nicht kennt man ja mal vorbei
schauen
vielleicht packt ich euch den mal die
beschreibung den finde ich durchaus cool
der nachdem er zur wehrmacht vor allem
pvp sehr viele games hat er so eine
serie mit über 200 folgen 240 noch ein
paar zerquetschte glaube ich finde ich
sehr cool und
ein bisschen was dazu und es gilt dabei
das heißt der ist doch durchaus ein
fähiger zeitgenosse wie die beamten bei
dem dann hinterher ins haus rein
hoffen wir dass der kleine fall markiert
auf exakt an recht kurz damit denen hier
kommt keiner ran bitte nicht bitte nicht
ich werde in solchen momenten viele
leute ich bin euch mal mit den viel zu
unachtsam viel zu viel zu fahrlässig
wenn ich einfach zulassen dass damit
theoretisch immer nachkommen könnte aber
ist diesmal noch mal gut gegangen
es tut mir leid können wir gerne einen
deckel auf den deckel
ihr könnt mir gerne deckel geben geht
mir einfach eine decke bestraft nicht
mit einem topfdeckel werde mich das
nächste beim release sehe also
spätestens auf der gamescom 215 dann
bringt mir einfach ein topfdeckel mit
und sagt es kay damals hast du dich in
dieses haus begeben ohne zu schauen ob
ihr jemand hinterher kommt und hast
riskiert fahrlässig riskiert dass du in
einer sehr sehr guten runde einfach
stirbst und dann gebt mir den topdeq in
die hand dann muss ich mit meinem
schicksal klarkommen weil das ist es
nicht leicht leute es ist nicht leicht
es ist nicht leicht so einen topfdeckel
einfach annehmen zu müssen damit
umzugehen da vorne ist henrik der berner
ich hoffe mal dass nicht der burner was
es weil wir uns angeht hat anwalt april
der fonds wird mich hier ganz gut weg
und alle auf einmal kurz zurück
fakt ziemlich live ab schade das war
knapp das war knapp
dann hendrik der berner uns sind doch
noch erledigt nachdem ihr von dem
anderen ein paar hits eingesteckt haben
aber er wird sagen das war doch eine
relativ gute runde machen keine cut
sondern wenn man jetzt diese
wunderschönen youtuber rechte und doch
wir machen kann müssen kurz waren bisher
ohne gewähr
meine sehr verehrten damen und herrn
diesen zurück in einer brände murmeltier
ganze klasse ich habe mich etwas
versprochen fast moment die games gesagt
wäre natürlich falsch gewesen konnte ich
jetzt gerade noch so verhindern
und wir haben ja eine komplette
rüstungen wer seine waffe kriegen
vorzugsweise naja walter jiji
da das waren equipment meine fresse
einfach fast voll alben mit zwei kisten
und noch eine 5 schadens punkte waffe
das gefällt mir sehr gut
das gefällt mir doch durchaus sehr gut
da können wir uns hier wahrscheinlich
bewähren
memphis tennessee hatte irgendwie eine
andere idee und haie trennen gerade auch
aber ich habe eine abkürzung und junge
leckte junge leckte ja was denn los mit
dem was ich denn los mit dir junge wie
viel sprit viel kann ich meinen steht
wahrscheinlich auch nicht er wird monat
seien nicht neu er ist einfach hübsch
aber jetzt da es keinen anderen weg
snack so wenn wir dem wasser ein
bisschen rum planschen okay das war
nicht der fall
da vorne kommen sieht aus als hätte
irgendwie den übelsten sucht der versuch
die modus an oder des fastens apps
laufen lassen
das wissen wir dass 1 hat da werden
wahrscheinlich nicht folgern auf so
einem kleinen vater sonst erst mal um
diesen werten luki kümmern jetzt geht
apologie ja was was was ist ja kein wort
will ich jetzt aber da hat oder wie
rotterdam a straight from the planet of
wer ist ein planet wisst ihr das noch
wer ist der planet auf dem cover lebt ja
warte hat war das nicht mir fällt gar
nicht einfangen wie fest gar nicht ein
schreibt meine kommentare wie der mann
auf dem cover lebt wer jansrud sind die
team glaube mich ne weil ja die sind ihm
die beiden team ohne fns auseinander zu
nehmen ist natürlich erst mal kritisch
aber geht haben jetzt gemacht sehr gut
chillig bogen immer mal kurz mit weil
wir viele haben sehr gut dann kann man
es ein bisschen besser wehren gegen
teams vielleicht auch hier diese
wunderschöne klitzekleiner ein idiot und
wo liegt die range liegt wieder unten ja
man hat manchmal diese bugs dass die
angelaufene zum hören block liegt aber
das spiel sagt die liegt auf dem unteren
muss man auf den unteren gehen um die
aufzugeben der denkt immer so ne
minecraft so ist es nicht
so geht es nicht hier drei teilnehmer
mit sehr gut er zieht eigentlich ganz
gut aus will ich mal sagen
doch durch bestehende mal nicht schlecht
nach dieser runde wieder schön viel zum
ist genommen gefühlt also soviel ist
erst morgens aufnehmen ich mach das
jetzt heute vor der uni vielleicht sich
ein bisschen verpennt aus wer überhaupt
gar nichts aber der brennt in den kann
man schon kurz kümmern kann man ja ums
land crafter war nicht so schlau andere
jetzt gerade nicht
bislang kostete dürfte durch auslösen
den habe ich mir so nicht mehr
jetzt wird gebohrt ja gut
alles taliban wahrscheinlich ein team
das ist sehr gut das ist der bestand den
anderen overclocking die labor an
das ist ein kleines problem das ist ein
klitzekleines problem
ich will dich runde gewinnen jetzt kann
ich es auch ich für diesen ekligen lava
brand der einen sowie eine stunde lang
beschäftigt deutschland sein allererstes
lange aufhören
meine fresse habe ich dafür ihr leben
verloren
meine fresse ja der kann sich jetzt geht
alles machen was er will
schade der war leider mit seinem
teampartner im deathmatch können wir
nichts machen
gegen zwei im dm ist heftig wir haben es
mit geschlagen glaube ich wirklich
gefallen gerne den daumen nach oben nach
los angeles in die kommentare schreiben
und an dem uns beim nächsten video wie
der haut rein macht's gut und